Oh, Lionus Sebastian is remoting in from
Texas to present our next award of the
evening. And the least crap GPU of 2025
award goes to AMD for the Radeon 970
XT. That's right, folks. After fumbling
for years, AMD has finally figured out
how to manufacture and price a GPU that
will actually sell. And all it took for
this to happen was for Nvidia to slip on
a banana peel, fall down an elevator
shaft, and then have a piano dropped on
them. As for the 9070
nonXT, it's also here. In all
seriousness, though, at 599 and 550,
both of these cards are well priced,
capable of both 4K gaming and actually
good ray tracing, and even add AI
powered upscaling capabilities. But as
per AMD's long proud tradition, they
also come with caveats like performance
and productivity and power consumption.
With that said, if they can stay in
stock, I think we're going to be able to
look past those little details toward a
brighter future for gamers and a bright
segue to our sponsor. Are you waiting
for that box to hear me? Our sponsor War
Thunder is waiting for you to hear their
comprehensive vehicle come back in. Take
control of more than 2500 tanks, planes,
helicopters, and ships. Go download and
join over 70 million players for free
now. Otherwise, I
will AMD says these cards, they're for
high resolution gaming. So, let's talk
1080p later and jump right into 1440p
rasterization where wow does the 9070 XT
ever make Nvidia look like a bunch of
greedy buffoons. It nearly matches the
performance of the RTX 5070 Ti while
coming in
$150 below the MSRP of that card, which
of course is an imaginary price that no
gamer has ever paid. Even the lesser
nonxt variant looks decent here, going
blowfor-blow with the 5070 across all of
our benchmarks. We even got the
occasional clear win for AMD, like in
Alen Wake 2, where the nonXT beats the
non TI by a whopping 17%. The only
definitive loss for AMD in our suite was
in Blackmth Wukong where the Ti beats
the X-T by around 9%. But the second you
factor in the price, AMD's small L turns
into a big W. In our Vulcan benchmark,
Red Dead Redemption 2, we do see some
worrying issues in frame pacing where
both of the new cards drop in ranking
because of their poor 1% lows despite
solid average FPS. So hopefully this is
something that AMD's team can work on
post launch. Overall though, we are off
to a great start. The 9070 XT is a clear
winner in performance and value. And as
for the 9070, well, it's about as bad a
deal as the RTX 5070, at least on paper.
And we'll talk a bit more about our
theory as to why later. First, I want to
talk about 4K, because unlike Nvidia,
AMD gave their $550 card sufficient VRAM
for ultra HD gaming. Sure, it's GDDDR6
and not GDDR7, but faster memory is
going to be irrelevant when you don't
have the capacity to keep up. And there
is no better illustration of this than
the way that the 9070 extends its lead
at higher resolutions, especially when
we look at the allimportant 1% lows,
which is what determines the smoothness
of your gameplay. Look at Last of Us
Part One here. The 9070 leads by a
whopping 23% over the RTX 5070. Why?
Well, look at the VRAMm usage on the
5070. It's full, which results in these
gameplay hitches that you see here.
Compare that to the 9070 or to Nvidia's
own cards that do have 16 gigs, and
those hitches disappear. And I mean,
sure, not everyone has a 4K monitor, and
these limitations don't rear their heads
in every game, or even most games, but
still, it's kind of embarrassing when
you're supposed to be the market leader
in gaming GPUs, right? Overall, the 9000
series does fall a bit short of true
60fps 4K ultra gaming, and in our tests,
it did not achieve the lofty margins
over the 7900 GRE that AMD promised in
their slides. But we're not that
disappointed yet because AMD included
ray tracing in their averages. And that
is a very different story with these new
cards. Before we look at those results
though, let's dive into what AMD has
done to bring about this generational
leap in performance. To me, the most
impressive thing is shrinkage. The new
monolithic die that underpins both the
9070 and 9070 XT should have been
codenamed frightened turtle. It's built
on TSMC's N4C process node and it cramps
92% as many transistors as the seen XTX
into just 2/3 of the die area. This
along with some major improvements in
performance per CU is what makes these
cards such a compelling value. Diving
deeper into the compute engine, we see
vastly improved matrix operations with
support for more data types, a new
dynamic register allocator, and
improvements to theuler. Combine this
with dual SIMD32 vector units,
overhauled AI accelerators, and beefed
up rate tracing capabilities, and you
get a card that can do a lot of
calculations all at once, especially
when it comes to rate tracing and AI.
But wait, there is more. Both cards get
an improved media engine, which provides
a considerable improvement for low bit
rate encoding during streaming.
YouTube's compression might make this
impossible to see, but to the human eye,
these Twitch optimized recordings of
Returnal, there's a clear improvement
over the Seven XTX, and it's even
difficult to distinguish AMD from
Nvidia's Nvank encoding. We'll talk more
about encoding later, but it's really
great to see AMD finally catching up
here. But where AMD is still behind is
in 42:2 hardware encoding and decoding,
which could make this a less desirable
option for professional video creators,
but it's unlikely to matter for
non-pros. Another slight disappointment
compared to the RTX50 series is AMD's
Display Point 2.1A, which are only UHBR
13.5 rather than UHBR20. So, these new
cards can still do 4K 240 Hz, but they
will rely on display stream compression
to do so. Not a huge deal to me. I find
it n imperceptible, but your mileage may
vary. Enough specs. Let's talk ray
tracing, where both the new cards beat
the 7900 XTX, a card that was
wellreceived at $1,000. Too bad they
don't fare quite as well against Nvidia.
In Allen Wake 2, the 9070 keeps up with
the 5070, showing just how bad the 5070
is, but the 5070 Ti provides
substantially better performance than
the 9070 XT, giving Nvidia one clear win
for their overpriced 50 series cards, or
one win so far. In the heavily
path-traced Blackmth Wukong, the 9000
cards handily outclass the 7000 series,
but fall substantially behind Nvidia's
latest. And as for
F124, AMD looks great across the board
here, while the 5070 gets beaten by its
own predecessor, the 4070 Super.
It the clown show. Removing Blackmth
Wukong from the equation, the 9070
family is neck andneck with the
competition, showing that AMD is no
longer two generations behind in ray
tracing. With that said, Blackmth Wukong
does in fact exist and shows that AMD is
still one generation behind, which may
matter in future games. And even in
AMD's own tech demo, we can see that
their path tracing implementations
struggle with boiling artifacts and
ghosting. That reminds me more of last
gen's ray reconstruction. Hey, but
here's hoping that AMD can continue to
catch up and maybe even surpass Nvidia
in the future. Maybe a guy can dream.
Hey, did we leave a 1080p raster? We ran
those numbers, so damn it, I want them
in the video. Even if the story remains
largely the same, the 570 Ti is still a
pretty bad deal, it does win, but its
margin of victory is so small compared
to the pricing chasm between these cards
that it's really hard to recommend. So,
if you are looking for an overkill 1080p
upgrade, the 9070 XT looks like a great
way to push huge FPS numbers in esports
titles or any title if you don't mind a
little AI upscaling. AMD said at one
point that they don't think AI is
necessary for upscaling and they could
get the same results using more
traditional means. Ah, spoken like a
company that did not have AI figured out
yet. The good news is that AMD has used
their slow start to squeeze a lot of
image quality out of temporal upscaling.
And now that they've added their
proprietary FP8 machine learning model
to improve upscaling even further, the
results are very impressive. Compared to
FSR 3.1, we see reductions in
artifacting and improvements in the
rendering of fine lines. There are a few
instances where it even beats DLSS4,
like with these butterflies in Horizon
Forbidden West. On FSR3, there's
unsightly trailing and dissolving, and
on DLSS4, they just kind of are blurry.
But with FSR4, they appear much crisp
and clearer than either of the other
technologies. Sure, when you look
closely, the artifacts are still there,
but it's a market improvement. Just like
haloing around detailed character
models, it's very heavily reduced, and
motion is just sharper in general. I
would say that at least when upscaling
to 4K, I found the image quality of FSR4
to be no more distracting than that of
DLSS4. But none of the reduced image
quality trade-offs matter if we don't
get better performance. And compared to
DLSS, FSR gives a less substantial
performance uplift at each quality
setting than Nvidia in both The Last of
Us Part One and in Horizon Zero Dawn.
But we do see that AMD's frame gen
provides a better uplift than Nvidia's
solution, which indicates that FSR 3.1
frame gen has less overhead than
Nvidia's multi-frame gen. While AMD
doesn't quite match Nvidia yet, this is
the most competitive their upscaler has
been ever. Except support is a problem.
Even though you can use the driver to
force the updated FSR4 model in games
with FSR3, AMD just has less games that
use FSR3. And unlike DLSS4, older cards
are not able to take advantage of the
new machine learning enhanced upscaling.
And AMD still doesn't have a competitor
for multi-frame gen yet. However, FSR4
does have frame gen, but it makes use of
FSR 3.1's frame gen implementation. But
you can bring frame gen to any game
using AMD's driver level fluid motion
frames now on version 2.1. But even with
the additional decimal point, AFMF still
sucks. Without game integration, you get
all these weird UI issues and overlays
get mangled with motion heavy heck and
even motion light scenes. Let's be real,
it's just frame interpolation and no
number of fancy names can change that.
And if the use case for Nvidia's frame
gen was already weak, AFMF feels like it
exists only so AMD can say actually we
support frame gen in way more games. But
no, it's got no one wants it. It's I
don't know who cares. Despite the swath
of shareholder approved AI junk in their
latest driver software, AMD falls pretty
well short of the mark here. There are
some great gen overgen improvements in
computer vision, but even the 4070 Super
manages a sizable lead over the 9070 XT.
The generational gains are even more
apparent in stable diffusion, but the
story remains the same. Finally, there's
AI text generation. And I bet AMD wishes
an AI could rewrite these benchmark
results where the new cards fail to
improve substantially over last gen and
get absolutely dunked on by Nvidia,
regardless of which model you're using.
The one silver lining is that either of
these cards can run all the same models
that the 5080 can and can run some that
the 5070 cannot thanks to AMD's generous
16 gigs of VRAM. I mean, it's only
generous compared to Nvidia, but thank
you guys. Don't be too thankful though.
AMD still needs to impress in content
creation where they do okay. For video
editing, the 9070 and 70 XT provide
good, but not exceptional performance in
Premiere Pro and Da Vinci Resolve. And
in Blender, the 9070 and 70 XT perform
about on par with the flagships from
AMD's last generation, but they still
just don't really get anywhere close to
Nvidia thanks to optics rendering. Yeah,
there was a transition that I was
written that made more sense before we
had to record this. Speaking of updates,
we have some encoder testing for you.
While AMD has made strides to improve
their encoder, they still fall behind in
quality compared to Nvidia and Intel,
especially at lower bit rates in H.264.
For this encoding test, we only set the
bit rate and no other parameters.
Depending on what encoder tweaks are
used, any of these cards could have
improved quality compared to our tests.
But the simplest way to improve quality
is use AV1. But sadly, we've excluded
the 7000 series from our results due to
a hardware bug. The good news is
everyone outputs better quality in AV1
and AMD is sadly still in last
place. We are almost there. Let's talk
power and thermals. Over the past
several generations, AMD has made some
substantial improvements to efficiency.
And in their announcement, they didn't
really talk much about it. I guess they
were being modest. In F-124, the 9070
pulls lower power on average than the
5070, but with less stable power
delivery, having transient spikes as
high as 321 watts. Speaking of which,
the 970 XT has a massive spike to 426
watts and its average is 309 watts,
which is already higher than its rated
TBP of 305 watts. And that propensity
for pulling profuse power can be found
in Combuster, where both AMD cards also
use more than their rated total board
power on average. But AMD is allowing
some partner cards to use a higher power
budget. So, I guess this isn't fully out
of spec, but I would definitely
recommend you stick with the
manufacturer recommended power supply
capacity. And I recommend you check out
PSU Circuit if you need to make an
upgrade decision. Lots of good info
there. Thankfully, despite the power
draw, thermals seem to be under control
on our provided Sapphire Pulse samples.
I'm sure in part to their use of
PTM7950, which you can buy for yourself
over at ltstore.com. That's a uh double
plug, double whammy. Self-promo, baby.
AMD doesn't feel the need to hide GPU
hotspot metrics like Nvidia does. And in
Combuster, we see that Sapphire's
coolers provide ample thermal headroom,
which is good. And they're a little big.
They're not obnoxious, but you know,
come on. it does allow the cards to stay
much cooler than say the 5070 or the
6T700 XT in F-124. So, if you're coming
from an older card, you can confidently
upgrade to either the 9070 or the 9070
XT and know you'll get a solid
improvement in raster performance and
ray tracing, which is a big plus for
folks who are on older ray tracing cards
like the 2000 series or if you're coming
from the 6000 series on AMD. It's just
it's good. It's good. It's cool. It's
nice. We like it. We're happy. I They
could be cheaper. They could be they
could be cheaper. There's kind of two
conclusions here, a short one and a long
one. The short one is that the 9070 XT
is a winner. If AMD can keep this thing
in stock and you have $600 to spend on a
gaming GPU, you are going to love this
thing and Nvidia needs to respond now or
AMD might actually take some real market
share for a change. The long conclusion
is that it seems like AMD is trying to
eat their cake and have it too here.
See, the XT's 599 price point is giving
real good guy AMD vibes, but the 9070
nonXT's price is giving maximized
margins while GPUs are in short supply
vibes. By matching the 5070 in both
price and performance, unfortunately,
you've also matched it in value. And
let's be real, the 5070 is not a great
value. Once nobody buys the nonXT,
because the XT is so much better for
just $50 more, you're going to end up
dropping the price on this thing after
the reputational damage has already been
done to it. Did you guys learn nothing
from the terrible initial reception to
the Seven XT? And it's not like you have
just reputation for days to give up. you
have nothing to compete in the high-end.
And sure, 85% of gamers do buy cards
under $700. I'm sure that's true. But
without a high-end card at all, you're
giving up precious mind share. I mean,
we didn't even bother to compare the
9000 series against Nvidia's last gen
flagship, the 4090, let alone their new
flagship. And yes, 16 gigs of VRAM at
550 bucks is nice, but it's a bummer
that the cheapest way to get more VRAM
in your lineup is still a last
generation 7900 XT. If you have no plans
to compete in the high-end, we need you
guys dominating the mid-range and
enthusiast segments, especially because
your non- gaming performance still kind
of lacking. Another thing that we need
to acknowledge in our longer conclusion
is the PlayStation shaped elephant in
the room. As impressive as these cards
are, there is still a strong argument to
be made that PC gaming has just plain
gotten too expensive when you can pick
up an all-in-one gaming box that will
already run at 4K for less than the MSRP
of a 9070 and even lesser if you buy it
secondhand. Sure, you'll pay more for
games and online services in the long
run, but boy is it ever a reasonable
upfront cost. But hey, maybe the best is
yet to come on the discrete GPU side.
AMD has announced that 9060 cards will
be coming in Q2, and those could provide
even better value, assuming, of course,
that AMD doesn't launch them at a high
price in order to maximize margin for
those ones, which grosses me out just
thinking about it. What I'm not grossed
out by is ending this video saying that
this is truly probably the best GPU
launch of the year, and save for Intel's
B580, perhaps the best launch of the
past several years, if they can keep it
in stock. But as per usual for you, the
consumer, there is no single right
answer. Just what's right for you. So
whether you want to go with these new
cards or pay extra for team green or go
for a console, all the power to you and
all the power to our sponsor in the
United States. Every 60 seconds that
pass, you lose 1 minute of life. But do
you know how to have infinite lives?
Download our sponsor, War Thunder. It's
the most comprehensive vehicle combat
game. You can blow up or be blown up
over and over. During research, over 90%
of a car essence happens when the cars
are moving. But do you know how not to
get into the car accident? Download War
Thunder again. Take control of more than
2500 old and new tanks, planes, and
ships from 10 major nations. Whatever
happens, you'll always be safe in your
room. If you skip your daily coffee run,
after a month, you will have enough for
30 coffees. But do you know what's even
better? Downloading War Thunder for free
on PC, consoles, and mobile. Over 70
million players are on the battlefield
waiting for you. That's way more friends
than you will meet at a coffee shop.
Thanks for watching guys. We are pretty
tired from doing backtoback to
backto-back GPU launches. Uh massive
shout out to you for watching and of
course to our labs team, our editors,
our camera team, our writers, everyone
for being part of it. I think there's a
little time to breathe. Wait, 9060 in
Q2. Okay. Okay. No, I Oh, and 5060 I
guess is coming. Well, whatever. If you
like this video, check
out, I don't know, 5080 review.